est-ce que vous avez lu mon livre vous
savez pourquoi je l'ai pas lu
trop de buzz j'étais bouché enfin je
gagne ma vie et j'ai toujours caché mon
métier je l'ai caché mon métier moi
j'avais caché votre métier c'est d'être
bouchée de faire devant tous les
Français pourquoi parce que je suis pas
un menteur parce que trop d'animaux sont
tués tous les jours je crois que ça j'ai
pas dit ça je vous ai posé des questions
attendez mais laissez-moi parler trop
d'animaux
d'accord c'est pas quelqu'un dit en
moyenne surface qui sont jetés à la
poubelle tant d'animaux tués pour rien
et vous me dites vous me reprochez oui
j'ai rien du tout oui j'ai un parcours
personnel oui je suis un parcours
personnel et je le revendique voilà
j'ai pas envie que ça parte en haut de
boudin
est-ce que vous avez lu mon livre vous
savez pourquoi je n'ai pas lu
trop de buzz j'étais bouché je gagne ma
vie et j'ai toujours caché mon métier je
l'ai caché